le soir tu vas chez silvia bourdon et tu
rencontres sylvia oui je sais j'ai
toujours eu les [ __ ]
ouais je
je suis un amoureux des plus complets je
crois que je me suis tapé tout est plus
de paris depuis que j'y suis je suis
arrivé à paris l'avait jamais rencontrée
ah non jamais jamais est ce qu est ce
qui m'a plu dans l tuer elle a un petit
minois rappeuse haïti touché et c'est
excitant quoi raconte quand tu vois ce
kit enfants de choeur et qui dit qu'elle
va peut-être dessus c'est tout à l'heure
et est sacrée c'est formidable et puis
bon je vais proposer mille balles pour
l'hôtellerie où il était un peu radin
assurent les bilbao
non c'était uniquement pour pour
déjeuner ou dîner par d'autres produits
doivent être à sa table j'étais autant
il m'a rien donné du coup mais comment
ça s'est passé alors tu as su tout de
suite que c'était un grand amour ou tu
t'es comment ça s'est passé
tu sais
elle est rentrée chez moi ouais et puis
j'ai vu qu'elle était un petit peu
prouver quand même
alors je me suis dit mathias il va en
profiter
une italie j'ai un grand appartement
pour moi tout seul machin tu t'installes
qui fait ta cuisine tout sa petite voix
puis on est là depuis depuis ce moment
là et finalement finalement tu vois
hélas commencé à faire la [ __ ] candidats
aux enfants de dieu et il a été sauvé
par le diable de l'alcoolisation par
rapport aux enfants du je suis calme
jeudi dans les suites de l'histoire et
vous aviez quand même temps vous êtes
ensemble ça va faire trois ans
mais quand même ça c'est vous trompez
pas rien vous êtes aussi le 30 mai le
droit à la mairie quant au repas
d'affaires pendantes où je dois je lui
dis allez hop ce mec là tu te tu te fais
tu dans le coin il sera content c'est la
maison des affaires voilà le marché
puisse allier et puy et effectivement ça
m'aide
vous êtes un couple moderne alors je ne
sais pas ans est resté longtemps
ensemble
mais savez que c'est un peu moi il y
aura deux d'avoir une famille unie vrai
coup de main et puis tu sais on est
mieux servie par des professionnels
c'est ce que je vais faire appel à des
pros quand tu as ta baignoire à réparer
et tu fais appel à un plombier et tu vas
voir c'est dur à trouver les bons bien
oui c'est dire qu'il faudrait bien leur
boulot et dans les buts aussi d'ailleurs
enfin il ya les vrais y avait là c'est
une vraie paix
tu le connaissais avant toi tu
connaissais rats qui rit quand même en
piste et estelle as tu détestais accueil
complètement c'est l'aspect du
mille-pattes déjà tous ont fait que j'ai
accepté de rencontrer bon j'ai vu
également il n'était pas une tête pas
dans son état normal
ouais alors c'est comment si tu veux
jeter coller avec le net depuis 30 ans
ah ouais et ses flingues et si celui-ci
d'ailleurs barbituriques donc c'est
évident que tu n'aies lettre que tu
calcules tu rentres tu prends un coup de
massue commence derrière les oreilles et
je me suis réfugiée dans les bras de ma
petite puce qu'est ce tu fais toi tu
nous fais professeur choron là arrivent
à sa portée le journal alors y avoir
alors alors tu vois il a emballé comme
ça chez les vrais héros ouais parce que
deux dont il ya un gadget et le
préservatif musicalta vont alors tu vois
bon il est enveloppé la gt est un
laboratoire qui va offert 120000 capote
ouais moi j'ai ajouté une petite musique
à l'élastique
alors si tu veux j'en ai jamais monté
importe faire la démonstration
alors tu vas une fois que c'est monté
sur la tutelle élastique
tu souffres dedans
non
ça fait rire les femmes et les vagues ça
les détend au et donc tuer ses deux bras
la salle sainte économique des disques
jeu l'aja n'y fit les whiskys des
disques du temps à la retraite tu fais
bien alors je suis très fier parce que
déjà c'est un journal qui porte mon nom
ben ouais ils ont depuis longtemps
profession il faudrait il fallait que ça
devienne un jeu où il arrive voilà dix
ans qui meurent là-bas il ya une limite
celle sur huit pages en pata les grands
comme big man tu as jean marie gourio
qui fait le rêve de po elle est ici j'ai
dit génial enfin c'est sans fin j'ai
vraiment petit format et à l'écouté
tombe bien vingt-cinq franprix dhabi
prix d'ami prix d'ami 25
et voici maintenant quelqu'un qui manque
complètement de toupet pourtant c'est un
maître ès provocations
le professeur chaud
est-ce provocation maître ès
provocations tu veux je met ma [ __ ] dans
le champagne pas encore à la fin
tout alla
c'est vrai que ton certificat d'études
en 11 ans oui c'est exceptionnel époque
c'était 14 7 et 14 et j'ai une dispense
et c'était à l'époque du marché le
terrain et le maréchal pétain m'a envoyé
une lettre de félicitations mon cher
enfant je vous félicite d'avoir réussi
et tout ça toi et donc à partir de ce
moment là j'ai chanté je sais moi qui ai
écrit la chanson maréchal nous voilà
c'est tout après le très touchant
nous voilà enfin la halle un talent tu
dis moi alors à 15 ans tu es parti faire
le tour de france à 15 ans je vendais
beau coup de fouet à 15 ans tu découvres
la branlette ray
tu sais tu étais tout petits à l'école
ta petite kate tu l'as rome tu la vois
monter tout doucement
et puis moi j'étais entouré de petites
soeurs trente deux petites fentes qui
sentait bon l'ammoniac
c'est vrai d'où ma question faisait
quand tu laisses tour de france à 15 ans
c'est au tour de france ccaf vite fait
ouais sept petits la france est un
village c'est comme si tu traverses de
rue qui va la grande rue dans la petite
rue l'hexagone
et puis après je me suis dit tiens je
m'engage pour la loge il s'est engagé
pour la gauche n'avait s qui m'a plu
dans la de chine c'est que y'avait pas
d'appeler et serrait pas de gendarmes il
ya un mois les mecs du contingent il n'y
avait que des voyous on tenait un
l'indochine c'était quatre fois la
france et on tenait sa avec 20000 voyous
à l'époque française après les
américains ils ont fui un million de
gros cons d'américains nous on est nuls
à deux chiffres dans quelques années
avec graville voyous en 55 rencontres
kavanagh non le champ d'à de chine
jeanne dans un hôpital militaire
tuberculeuse 100% insauvable la
tuberculose site un poumon atteint
entendant les vins mais moi j'avais les
deux ouais qu'est ce qu'on fait moi je
me suis évadé l'hôpital c'est comme ça
gerrit cgt condamné la terreur bien
parce que tu fumes tout le temps était
besoin à un moment je me suis guéri avec
l'alcool ingéré un grand dommage à faire
aujourd'hui je profite de ton émission à
10 ans parce que il n'ya pas beaucoup
d'émissions comme la diam 1 1
si allah mais elles sont pas pareil que
les ce que je dis rien mais j'ai un
grand et un grand hommage rendre à
l'alcool et au tabac sans l'alcool et le
tabac je ne serais pas là je serai voir
c'est l'alcool le tabac et même
peut-être la véronique et ne saurait
jean baucou hommage dans la vérole tout
ça à tous ces petits virus à tous et
toutes ces petites fantaisies conseil
condamne un et tous les gros quand titi
qui me supprime sa qui balançaient
travaux l'eau du bois de boulogne vous
rendez compte c'est beau travelo et du
bois de boulogne comme il était beau à
paris on n'est pas voir notre dame
ces gares go il trouve la gueule comme
ça et qui ne suce même pas
en 1960 qui font de hara kiri
c'est un accident ouais je rencontre
kavanagh je vendais des jours la rue tu
vois je rencontre kavanagh reiser fred
topor machin il me disait champ que ce
tube rend là avec ton paquet ce jour de
son droit viens avec nous tu vas nous tu
vas être d'autres éditeurs et puis j'ai
été l'éditeur
alors il ya eu donc bal tragique à
colombey le journal était bien lancée
les lundis soirs eu des trois ports sont
devenus des rendez-vous obligé de tous
les dessinateurs et gagner et du groupe
i et des groupes et sa tirade y écoulent
alors explique moi comment ça se passe
et rapport qu'elle a paru des trois
portes
c'est à la fin du journal ont donc ont
bouclé hier offres ont bouché vraiment
les trous ouais et du journal et des
groupes et qui est venu nous voir
je me souviens d'une anecdote si je peux
te raconter la soul en cueillir tout ce
que tu veux
j'ai un copain âge je vais pas dire le
nom c'est un grand dessinateur de
charlie hebdo et il était il a fait une
grosse [ __ ] pas dire il avait une grosse
[ __ ]
il avait une copine et une copine qui
faisait du porno au théâtre saunier
c'est pour te lire pourtant et je ferme
le bureau tout le monde était parti sauf
lé mois
et puis elle ne prend à part et me dit
chan est ce que je peux te demander un
service à juillet ma chérie comme tu
veux et puis elle me dit cgem je dit pas
son nom
il est marié les enfants
bien trop grosse [ __ ] est ce que tu
pourrais m'en culé ce soir
je suis dit ma chérie moi j'ai une [ __ ]
normal
ce sera un plaisir pour moi c'est les
anecdotes
bien de charline sa une que j'ai retenu
cinq chansons sérieuses explique alors
pour le moment en dehors de tes mémoires
tu fais un journal pour les enfants de 4
à 7 ans qui s'appelle gros dada qu'on a
un grand dada voilà alors parle-nous de
gros dada ça c'est ma nouvelle passion
alors tous tous les tous les lecteurs
qui me connaissent ils 10h sur moi tu
connais tu as passé ta vie a fait rire
les gros cons maintenant tu fais rire
les petits cons ouais les gosses en
rafale il couche avec le négoce vous
leur payer grenade à y couche avec les
petites filles se ralentit et où il
couche avec ça y est cros dada c'est la
drogue et des petits vivent dont je suis
le fils de satan
je sais que papa montant 10 mois lors il
ya longtemps que j'ai envie de te faire
le questionnaire de proust au hall qui
c'est celui-là tu vas voir
pour quelle faute à tulle le plus
d'indulgence celle de ce fait reculer
quel est un personnage historique favori
parent a reculé quelconque
il n'y avait pas un maître qui joue au
bilboquet way henri iii quoi quelle est
ta qualité préféré c'est l'homme qu'est
ce fascicule un petit peu d'autant plus
que chez la femme aussi l'impression
préféré reculer les gens qui aurais tu
aimé être un autre qu'est ce que tu as
tu réussi le plus chez des amis
qu'est ce que tu as beau être le plus
c'était un ami dos ferrand une
quelconque principal défaut ne pas se
faire en chine
ce que tu déteste par dessus tous ceux
qui sont pour éduquer le don de la
nature que tu voudrais avoir à [ __ ]
comment aimerais tu mourir fois la
culbute de rôle clé
quelle est ta devise ont tué ou arthur
nous les uns les autres
alors bon j'arrête nature oui arrêtons
ça tend la main vers sérieux la question
que j'ai posée maintenant on n'est pas
dans le questionnaire de proust
sk tournage avec ce que tu t'en vois
quand même à moins à gérer sur les
folies baril mais enfin cigarettes
alcool quand même un dakar est ce que tu
as besoin d'accessoire le mode mission a
cédé je n'aime pas tellement non j'aime
pas moi le godemiché c'est un petit peu
comme une poupée que je formate petite
fille charlotte
ouais dans le demain je vais offrir un
godemiché ouais mais je parle pas comme
ça je vais je y pendant deux yeux du
rouge à lèvres ce soit sur tient avec
belle poupée ma petite chérie
[Musique]